[음악]
네 사 간다 오늘은 신당동에 갔었는데
어제가 너무 더워서 좀 급하게 피신을
했습니다 폭염주의 보더라고요네 좀
회사 근처로 좀 복귀를 했습니다
그래서요 부분 좀 양해해 봐 주시면
좋을 것 같고 제가 신당동을 좀
돌아봤어요 상권의 역사라는 지금 현재
신당동 사건이 좀 어떤지 여러분들한테
좀 알려 드리도록 하겠습니다 신당동
유래가 그 신당 분들이 되게 많았던
곳이었어요 무당이나 그쪽에 계시던
분들이 그쪽이 좀 많이 밀집해서
살면서 그쪽으로 좀 이제 동 명칭이
지어졌다 그러더라고 조선 시대 때
그러다가
1950년도 이제 딱 그 62어 전쟁
끝나고 나서 마봉리 할머니가 거기
이제 떡볶이 타운에 그쪽에 이제
떡볶이 가게를 내면서 그쪽 인근에
이제 떡볶이 가게들이 좀 많이
생겨나기 시작했습니다 그러면서 신당동
그 떡볶이 타운이 좀 조성이 됐어요
신당동 떡볶이로 되게 유명하다 근데
최근에 거기 인근이 되게 좀 해졌죠
그래서 그 떡볶기 타운 있는 데가
아니라 거기 건너편에 신당역에서 이제
12시와 한 두시이 정도 부분의 정식
명칭은 신당동이 아니라 황학동에
황동에 힙함 업체들이 좀 많이
들어오면서 동으로 좀 변경이 됐습니다
네트로 감성 그런 감성들로 좀
만들어진 그런 상권인데 어 거기가
일단 초반에
주신당이라는 업체가 들어가면서
그때부터 좀 바뀐 거 같아요 그래서
제가 당 아까 들어가 봤는데 바깥의
모습은 좀 이렇게 어 뭐지 약간 점집
있가 하는데 들어가면 되게 멋진 빠가
있거든요네 그것처럼 좀 이렇게 외가는
허름하지만 안에 들어가면 좀 되게
힙한 어 그런 가게들이 좀 많이 몰려
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
신당역 1대 상권을 조사한 내용을 좀
보니까 2021년도 비교해서 매출이
거의 한 40% 정도 상승했다고
그만큼 되게 좀 젊은 사람들 이좀
많이 찾는 곳이라고 시면 될 거
같습니다 신당동 상권이 좀 재밌는게
신당역 쪽에는 좀 이렇게 20대
30대 분들이 좀 많고 그다음에 신당
그 중앙시장 있는 쪽에는 좀 어르신
분들이 많아요 그래서 약간 이게 좀
믹스되는 상권이라 그래야 되나 약간
그런 느낌의 상권입니다 근데 거기
인근에 좀 대표적인 맛집을 좀
소개하자면 그 하니칼국수 집이 있는데
거기가 되게 맛집이에요 그래서 점심
시간에 사람들이 굉장히 많이 찾는
곳이고 그리고 두 번째로는 이제
금대지 식당은 다 아시죠 그래서
신당역이랑 청구역 그 사이에 있는
금돼지 식당은 최근에 컴이 실제로
가서 어 거기서 이제 뭐 식사도
했었고 그래서 거기는 아까도 봤지만
어 웨이팅이 있을 정도로 되게 좀
많이 찾는 어 그런 대표적인 그런
맛집이라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다
그리고 세 번째는 이제 아무래도
떡볶이 타운이 있다 보니까 마봉리 한
머니 그 떡볶이 집을 많이 찾는 거
같은데 대표적으로 맛집은 좀이
정도라고 보시면 될 거 같고 데이터
정보를 좀 보면은 신당역 주변으로
매출이 좀 많 올라왔던 것으로 좀
보여집니다 가게들도 계속 생겨나고
있어요네 신당역 주변으로 그리고
아까도 말씀드렸지만 그 힙하다는 곳의
동네는 황학동 있니다네 여러분
전체적으로 좀 불러서 신당역 주변
상권네 이렇게 해서 불러서 좀
얘기하는데 그 부분 참고하시면 좋을
것 같습니다 그래서 신당동 좀 투자
사례를 말씀드릴 건데 저희가 이제
예전에 2020년도에 신당동에
중계했던게 있어요 그건 이제 신당동
상권이 좀 별 개긴 하지만 약수역
바로 합에 있던 그런 이제 고깃집
들어와 있던 건물을 저희가 중계를
했었거든요 근데 그거를 부신 다음에
아예 메디컬 빌딩으로 신축을 했습니다
1층에 약국 있고 나머지 다 병원이
들어 있어요 그 약수역에서 제일
랜드마크 건물 중에 하나입니다 그
건물 같은 경우에는 그 남산타운
아파트랑 같이 있어 가지고 이런 배우
세대가 많거든요 병원에 대한 수요가
되게 많아서 신축하기 너무 좋은
땅이었어요 그리고 준주거 지역이어서
거의 용적률을 400%지
성공 사례 중에 하나로 좀 잡았습니다
그래서 뭐 신당동 그런 뭐 상권 있는
곳은 아니지만 배우 세대에 되게
안전한 그런 뭔가 신축 사례라고 좀
보여집니다 저희가 이제 신당동
상권이라고 말씀드렸는데 신당동이 되게
커요네 그래서 제가 계속 뭐 힙이라는
데는 그 신당역에서 그 황학동 부분네
그쪽이 제일 요즘에 핫한 업체들이 좀
많이 들어오고 그리고 아까 그
약수역이랑 청구역 사이 그 금대
지식당 있던 데에다 상권이 좀 있고
그리고 이제 남산타운 있는데 여기는
완전 별개 상권입니다 여기는 아까
말씀드렸던 그런 배우 세대 어
상권이라고 보시면 될 거 같아요 지금
요즘에 또 많이 투자하는 데가
신당동에서 신라 호텔 올라가는 길
있거든요 거기도 좀 많이 사는 거
같습니다 거기 뷰가 되게 좋아요
서울시 내에서 좀 특색 있는 길이긴
해서 뭐 그런 부분 때문에 조금
그쪽에 투자 하지 않나 싶기는 한데
거기도 이제 신당동이 완전 별개의
곳이라고 좀 보시면 될거 같습니다
그래서 신동도 좀 이렇게 많이 나눠져
있다 그리고 거기 이제 워낙 노후화된
건물들이 많아서 이렇게 재개발
지역으로 좀 묶인 곳이 있어요 그래서
거기는 이제 돈이 좀 묶일 수도
있습니다 그래서 저 개인적으로는 정비
구역에 묶인 지역에 투자하는 걸
권하진 않습니다 그런 지역을 좀
피해서 투자를 하는게 중요한 거 같고
노후화된 건물들이 많으니까 나중에
건축행위 할 때 꼭 경계 측량을 좀
하셔야 돼요 땅을 넘어간 건물들이
되게 많거든요 예전에 지은 거예요
그래서 그래서 그런 부분을 좀 잘
확인하시면 좋을 것 같습니다 저는
전망을 저희가 알고 있는 그런 뭔가
다 똑같은 임차인 그 약간 다 뭔가
비슷한 건물 그런 있는 상품들보다
그런 신당동에 있는 그런 뭔가 감성
있는 그런 건물이랑 감성 있는 뭔가
그런 임차인 힙한 임차인들이 좀 많이
있으면서 그니까 새로운 경험을 하고
싶은 젊은 분들이 또 앞으로 많이 갈
거라고 생각을 하고 그리고 인근에
아까 말씀드렸던 그 재개발 이슈가
있기 때문에 아파트 가 들어오건
한다라고 하면은 배우 세대도 되게 좀
탄탄한 그런 곳이라고 보시면 될 거
같습니다 아직 다만 좀 뭐 좀 부족한
거는 이게 상권이라는게 이어져야
되거든요 식당을 와서 밥을 먹고
그다음에 카페를 가서 차를 마시고
그리고 뭐 술을 먹고 그리고 뭐
쇼핑도 하고 막 그래야 되는데 아직
그게 다 완성돼 있지 않은 거 같아요
만약에 그런 것까지 좀 갖춰진다고
하면 조금 더 상권이 좀 더 커질
여지도 좀 있어 보여서 저는 앞으로
좀 신당동 상권을 지켜보시면 좋을 것
같습니다 마지막으로 이건 약간 번의
얘긴데 그 약수역에 원래 이제 고가가
있었어요 그 고가 때문에 거기
사거리가 매우 미관상 안 좋아
보였습니다 근데 그게 철거가 되면서
약수역 그쪽 인근이 완전 좀
바뀌었어요 이미지도 바뀌고 그래서
저는 그렇게 좀 이런 고가라는 낡은
거라든지 그런 거를 좀 철거하거나
공원으로 좀 이쁘게 꾸며 가지고 좀
이렇게 사람들이 걸어갈 수 있게 좀
하면은 좋을 것 같습니다 오늘은 는
과거와 현재가 공존하는 신당동 어
당동에 다녀왔습니다이 영상이 마음에
드셨다면 구독과 좋아요 그리고 이제
만약에 상권이 궁금한게 있으시다고
하면 댓글로 남겨 주시면 어 제가
직접 찾아가서 빌사남 간다 촬영을 또
하도록 하겠습니다 여러분들 빌딩은
빌사
[음악]
Find my peace of
mind I should